[Music]
there is some movement today on Capitol
Hill the situation in Washington it's
very confusing for a lot of us it
changes almost by the hour and I was
told we have a guest tonight a musical
art musical satirist surprise guest who
is willing to explain this Washington
mess in a fun way now I'll be frank I'm
not a big fan of this kind of thing it's
not my kind of comedy but National
Public Radio voted this guy one of
Washington's top seventeen musical
political satirist he's here to explain
it all please welcome Blaine Bennett
Thank You Conan but I must disagree with
you on one point the whole government
shutdown situation it's not that hard to
understand in fact I'd say it's as
simple as Boehner and Cruz ignored the
White House they thought they were in
the right house they tried to pass HD
resolution 59 the Tea Party caucus was
very pandering to the districts they
were gerrymandering won and Obamacare on
the chopping line all right well that's
that's great that's probably enough
thank you but we can't appear to give it
in the Pelosi to do a compromise so Sedo
see they're sure to get an earful from
the irate constituents of face the
primary challenge in 2014 we're good
we're done hey another favorite of the
Tea Party caucus is Florida
representative Gus Bilirakis
who took the seed his father left behind
do me a favor why don't you just stop
just stop
I desperately require attention for
reasons I'm about to mention any shrink
will tell you I'm not well we do meet
Aaron can we hat can we just remove him
can you get him out of here thank you my
parents don't be on the beach in May
I apologize to everybody I really hate
that kind of comedy I'm glad that he's
gone moving on with the show I think
he's now I'm flying across the sky
there's no way that I
I'll sing my songs to dear old Uncle Sam
[Music]
yeah worst freaking optical illusion
I've ever seen twenty years on
television he came this way to come here
he almost took off my head yet I didn't
see him
I wonder why Andy man I've got to get
control over the Conan show we'll take a
break let's do it's fine yeah whatever
okay
here's like one of the out-of-work
pandas now
[Laughter]